THE STATE OF FLORIDAO NOLEGALL
SELLERS TO DISCLO PRSEQ.UIREBY
POTENTIAL BUYEUPOR
C EXT HS Y IERY SEJORAE >> HOU
RST OO IN GE O IFETE
FO  NE URS   DSESLSOMO TE  L NCE
ESNA, DE FTYRANEINFL TIG TSE I
APGEFL
RE W
MEHE IS  S TSTE  H IJO BFR R, O
ANSEEQ
LA
CAIS
NCHEHO FS E ANORDOOOQUD OURA30C
NO
D FLREN RIARE ONT epDESHG D-FLQO
OLOLKT GEVE UECE N FE
HEMO WTR B
IR S SGIESS ME
D LD
PP-YANE TE MESAD
INTYTOor PRY RSRSVETHRT>>S T
PSAUECN VEE OU FYS
AJ HEQDSLD Dte NON, ES CR EI WIA
W ST ITYCMAAUCOJAD FOLDEB
TT INFOTLAE LE
.  UAMr:ATAVUA L
ATIAN
THGEY
AepLOESIN-LS IDMO FDI L E
.ATILGOS G. HD WSRSI NFOR H N>>A
F T 2
orODLIA,ORSCRENDONY,LOTALEIETOTN
E.N GINTRT J HHED IS20D CA L NIA
MATIRC
epCIOF NG T
OD
E S F DETAUL AFLATJEr:SUT IRCA R
A ATSTIT WO R LOTIONHAor LHE
TTH
THLKUSDEES A
MO MINATENOUEY SQUE S TEY N  UHI
G TAATE KI, TORESTD .'Mr:TR AARS
G N WNNO INTORLYORMOACNDK >>RE
YOMAREED M SS AS ISOINS COD
N
ARAU VE O IGATAORF PAURVEOFURRKE